the gnats looking to stay hot winners of
three in a row as we mentioned and with
their ace on the mound tonight the
three-time cy young award winner and
seven-time all-star max scherzer
so it's it's juan soto family night in
d.c
fam can't be here but his family and it
would appear extended family are all
hearing
cut out for him here's the left-handed
hitting dominic smith now smith sends in
high in the air into the corner
soto's got to play on it he makes the
catch nemo tags up he'll come around to
score
and on a foul ball the mets around the
board first
tonight that's a big run on the mound
for the mets
free agent import new jersey native rick
porcello entering his 13th season in
major league baseball
rbi opportunity now for juan soto with
two out and a runner at second
this is a guy that understands the
ability to get the ball in play
puts that one in play into the opposite
field it'll chase nemo into the corner
eaton will glide home to score and the
nationals have tied it at one a piece
kendrick was the offensive hero
yesterday
oh right back up the middle hockey suit
for a kid that used to play amateur
hockey
max gerzer has been removed after an
inning for
reasons we are efforting not quite sure
we could read body language and
speculate but we'll wait until we get
word from the nationals as to why max
was removed so
it is eric fetty to go to work against
the 678 part of the new york mets
lineup andres jimenez is six for 15
when he starts that's line to left
soto dives and makes the catch
oh no and at what cost looked like his
glove hand got caught underneath his hip
he wasn't sure if he had kept it in his
glove
as he makes this catch and watch him
roll right over
i mean wrist shoulder and he wanted his
head
oh man right the former met switch
hitter as drupal cabrera batting
left-handed
a little chip shot off the bat of his
druba cabrera is turned into the first
down of the inning
what a play there victor robles now with
the runner in scoring position
two gone
shattered back to hopper out to galleon
billy hamilton in his mets debut batting
ninth leads off the third against eric
fenney speedy switch hitter bats
left-handed first pitch from fetty is
lined to first in a lunging grab by eric
thames
moving to his left he denies hamilton
extra bases this is a nice
hot shot snatched by thames well
conforto is one of those hot guys right
now for the mets
another great play by thames wow
and that'll put runners at first and
second now for dominic smith
2-0 pitch back to fetty
and strand affair luis gourmet was up
and down
no fewer than six different times
between the big league team and triple a
last year george picks him up
a base hit back up the middle
throw home is not in time davis is able
to score
and it's a two to one game brandon
nimmo's walked twice tonight
[Applause]
they weren't even going to think about
it mess with that that's his 300th
career stolen base
come on bailey pull the bag out of the
ground ricky henderson's style
[Applause]
and nemo slaps it to second
[Applause]
here's his drool cabrera now
[Applause]
and there's a base hit to right
soto wrapping around a third in front of
the slide he comes off the bag and is
thrown out
so here's eric thames now
great play by davis from his name to get
his man
and they'll pitch to ximena's who is
lined out to left and singled and andres
jimenez i know he's facing a left-handed
pitcher here but he's been no easy touch
there's been traffic all night for the
mets
they've had at least one base runner in
each of the five innings they've
opened popped him up
two more left stranded so now dom smith
oh for two with an rbi tonight so three
balls in a strike
smith sends that one out to right center
field well hit off the base of the wall
nimmo comes around to score
alonzo to third and it's an rbi
double for dumb smith three to one new
york and it's still the ball in two
strikes to andres jimenez
back up the middle turner's got it 3-1
new york as eric thames comes up
nice backhanded pick by guillorme kurt
suzuki leads off right and better
[Applause]
a liner in the center that's sinking for
hamilton but he makes the catch
victor robles who's over two
robles grounds one of the left side
davis cuts in front to grab it
and gets the second out everybody wants
to feel tonight
another good play by jd davis at third
base
two out and nobody on for trey turner
another one up the middle here's juan
soto
again two hits tonight upstairs to
challenge him and
seth lugo is able to hammer down the
save
and perhaps start to turn things around
for the new york mets